un véritable magicien du golfe avec sa
collection de club il fait disparaître
les balles le golfeur américain david
edwards joue de sa technique pour un
spectacle sur le green de saint quentin
en yvelines devant une cinquantaine de
personnes
ce que j'ai vu c'est un extraterrestre
mais quand on joue au golf déjà joué à
peu près bien c'est tellement difficile
enfin là il ya du monde entre nous il
m'a proposé de faire le concours de deux
rails avec un team et sur un shaft et
c'est vrai que sur le coup dit bah ouais
ça va le faire mais en fait non ça fait
pas du tout parce que même si on sait
jouer au golf c'est pas quelque chose
d'évident du tout comment ils jouent et
citez moi je pensais pas ça je pensais
qu'il faisait du coup pas aussi loin de
chez eux avec un driver de deux mètres
un pavé utilisé comme outil ou un
mélange entre golf et tennis
david edwards qui propose une palette de
styles ici pas de stratagèmes l'artiste
sort les tire de son chapeau un moment
de partage avec les spectateurs
j'aime bien m'amuser avec les gens si tu
arrives à les renvoyer chez eux avec le
sourire tu arrives à partager une part
de ce super jeu avec eux peu importe que
tu sois vieux ou jeunes tout le monde
peut devenir le meilleur aujourd'hui
joueurs mais pas seulement le showman se
lance dans une série d'imitations du
golfeur espagnol miguel angel jiménez au
président américain donald trump
un spectacle pour donner une leçon de
golf sur le ton de l'humour le secret
quand vous jouez à ce jeu et de ne pas
avoir des leçons de golf et ne pas
s'entraîner vous avez les leçons mais
vous avez les entraînements mais
sortaient de ce cadre pour prendre du
plaisir et si vous prenez du plaisir
dans ce jour en jour m yogo
[Applaudissements]